actually most of us know what direct
variation is it is just the name that
scares us the name direct variation does
sound scary here's an example to
understand it one book costs 10 Rupees
so how much will two books cost two
books will cost 2 multiplied 10 that is
20 rupees we multipli the cost of one
year to the number of units and
similarly three books will cost 3
multiplied by 10 that is 30 rupees you
can see that as the number of books
increases the total cost also increases
by the same
factor this is called direct variation
wasn't it
simple let's erase this and form a table
so that you can understand
better in the first row we have the
number of books books and in the second
row we have the total
cost for one book The cost is 10 Rupees
for two books the total cost is 20
rupees for three books the total cost is
30 rupees and so
on now let us form a new row to write
the ratio of number of books to the
total cost we will find this ratio for
each of the five cases
the ratios we get will be very
interesting in the first case the number
of books is one and the cost is 10 hence
the ratio is 1 by 10 in the second case
the number of books is 2 and the total
cost is
20 hence the ratio is 2x 20 look at
these two ratios carefully what's
special about them yes they are the same
same this ratio can be written as 1X 10
if the numerator and the denominator are
divided by 2 so let's erase this and
write this as 1 by
10 in the third case the ratio is 3x
30 this can again be reduced to 1x 10
and similarly in all the cases the ratio
will be 1 by
10 the ratio of the number of books to
the cost will remain a constant it is
always equal to 1x 10 this is direct
variation let's understand it in terms
of
variables let the number of books be Y
and let the cost of books be X this
ratio will then be y by X hence we can
write y by X is equal to 1x 10 which is
a
constant now you know where the constant
comes from many students study direct
variation as y by X is a constant but
have no idea what the constant
is if we multiply both sides by X we get
Y is equal 1X 10 x this is another way
in which direct variation is studied Y
is equal to KX where K is a
constant remember this constant can have
any numerical value in this example if
one book would have cost 20 rupees then
the constant would have been 1 by
[Music]